all right guys
bang bang i have morgan here i'm
extremely excited about this mainly
because uh i don't think there's a
single thing that i've ever read that
you've written
where i've been like wow that wasn't
worth my time so uh thanks so much for
doing this man
well thanks for having me and and maybe
that's a dare i can try to see if i can
write something next week
that would that would uh be below your
expectations but thank you
it just wastes everyone's time okay
let's start with uh with your background
for those that don't know you
um kind of where did you grow up and and
what did you do uh to get to uh finance
and investing and writing
yeah so i grew up most of my life around
and in the lake tahoe area of california
and i grew up skiing i was a ski racer
from the time i was a young kid
um i was in karate for a long time i
have a second degree black belt in
karate
that was in a different life though
don't pick a fight with me now because i
you you would hurt me
but um but the skiing was an important
part of my
childhood particularly in my teen years
because myself and a lot of my other
ski racing friends that i was that i was
growing up with we thought we didn't go
to high school
we did this independent study program
that was designed
for juvenile delinquents for which we
were not we were just
we needed the time during the week to
ski and to train and to travel to races
so we didn't have any high school we did
this the independent study program was
like
i took a couple of tests and when i was
16
they handed me a diploma i did nothing
for it we did nothing like i basically i
have an eighth grade education
um but i went from eighth grade to
college and that was that was
really difficult for me to do because i
started college when i was 20. so i
started a little bit later and since i
had an 8th grade education i had to
start
from ground zero because not only had i
not done anything
in you know six years since eighth grade
but i'd forgotten everything like i had
not
exercised my brain and during my teenage
years i wasn't reading i wasn't paying
attention i wasn't watching
like nothing i was completely zoned out
of anything intellectual
so i had to really start at ground zero
in college with like the
the most basic like the first math
course that i took in college was
literally like
this is a negative number and when you
add a negative number to a positive
number like that it was the most basic
you can get so that was
kind of a struggle for me but i i still
just kind of grinded it out and
it took me like six years to graduate
college so i was older than my peers
which i think was good because i took it
more seriously
and i always knew throughout that time
that i wanted to go into investing
investing just fascinated me i didn't
know anything about it but it fascinated
me if i'm honest a lot of it was because
i was
20 and investors at the time or people
in finance at the time
just had seemed like they had so much
power and prestige and allure and i
wanted the bentley i wanted the house
and the hamptons like all of that really
appealed to me it doesn't anymore but it
really did to me then
um so i wanted to get into investing in
finance
and the the the plan was investment
banking because that's like everyone
else
every young male in college every every
20 year old male wants to be an
investment banker
like of course that's that's not true
but that's that's what it felt like to
me
and i quickly realized i got an
investment banking internship in my
junior year
and i realized that it was just pure
hell it was just awful it was a jo like
the culture of it the hazing aspect of
it the
shut your mouth and work till 4am aspect
of it was so
antithetical to everything that i wanted
to do but also like the culture in which
i'm able to do good work in
so i that that quickly ended and i
needed to do something else
in finance i had no idea what it was
going to be i didn't have any backup
plans but i had a friend at the time who
was a writer for the motley fool
um and he said hey mindful's hiring
writers you're interested in investing
i had no writing background particularly
because i had i had no high school
education i had no like i you know i
really had
absolutely no history of writing at all
anything
because i applied thinking that hey
they're not going to hire me but if they
do
i'll do this for like three or six
months or something before i find
another finance job
and i ended up staying at molly full for
10 years and just fell in love with the
process of writing
i've always been you know fascinated in
investing but writing was something that
you know my first year or so at the
motley fool was
the the writing part i didn't like it
was hard it was work i wasn't
any good at it but i just slowly started
falling in love with the writing
part of it not just the investing but
just the process of sitting down
and thinking through a topic and being
like what is a unique point that i think
is interesting how can i explain that
really quickly in a fun way with a story
how can i get my point across
effectively i really love that aspect of
it
so that's that's where i started my
writing career i started the motley fool
when i was a junior in college
ended up staying there for 10 years and
then i joined the collaborative fund
four years ago which
is a vc private equity firm but my whole
role there
is writing and speaking and that's
effectively all that i do so my whole
career
i've been a financial writer and that's
that's all i want to do
it took me a while to get there even if
even if you went back maybe like
four years ago not that long ago i would
have said yeah i'm a writer now but i
aspired to do something else i didn't
really know what it was
um many years ago i started out to get
my cfp
uh i didn't i didn't get it i abandoned
that but i've it wasn't until the last
couple years that i've embraced with
both hands that i'm a writer and this is
what i want to do this is what i love to
do and that's what i'm always going to
do
so a lot of people are probably not
familiar with the motley fool
i grew up in north carolina and so uh
ended up meeting a lot of people who had
worked there
or kind of new people there uh and it's
a pretty impressive business so maybe
just
explain a little bit about the motley
fool um kind of business model
and then uh talk a little bit about
being there for 10 years i'm assuming
you got there
relatively early in the life cycle of
the business and kind of no no
no well so so they they started in 1994.
they were one of the first kind of
online communities it started as an aol
chat room in 94.
and by 1999 they were enormous i think
it was a billion dollar company like
everything was in 1999
and then they had a big you know kind of
fall in in the dot com crash but they
survived
and by the time i joined in 2007 it was
very much you know an established
13 year old corporation with several
hundred employees
it grew while i was there i think today
it's maybe approaching 500 employees
something like that i won't get into
like the
business metrics but it's bigger than
you think that's that's what i'll tell
most people it's a it's a it's a
thriving business and the whole business
is newsletter subscriptions
um subscriptions to stock picking
products and they have mutual funds and
financial advisory products and whatnot
it's a pretty diverse
uh a diverse business and it was a great
place to work
that's why i stayed there 10 years you
know i i'm not
i i kind of was when i started but i'm
not anymore and wasn't most the time i
was there i'm not a stock picker
and it's a stock picking place but it's
so it it
in some ways it was a little bit of a
interesting fit for me but it was such a
good place to work it's filled with so
many good people who are still some of
my closest friends that i
really enjoy my time there so if you're
working in a place that has i'll call it
a culture of stock picking or a bent
um that it leans that way and that's not
your game
how do you kind of navigate that and how
did you kind of find what
you thought was kind of your angle on
finance investing
in the markets for me it it it it
actually meshed
fairly easily because uh to me but my
whole investing what i'm interested in
what i think is most important
is investing behavior just your ability
to think about risk
and greed and long-term thinking and how
people think about
opportunity and scarcity that's all i'm
interested in and whether you are an
index investor or a stock picker or
private equity investor or a bitcoin
investor doesn't matter
those topics of greed and fear and
long-term thinking like the psychology
of investing the psychology of money
is applicable to everyone regardless of
how you are investing
so even though i was i was investing in
index funds and everyone else at the
you know sitting at the desk next to me
was picking netflix stock like the the
common denominator of what i was
thinking about was applicable to
everyone
so even though i may have seen like kind
of an outsider there i think the stuff
that i wrote about
it was still hopefully helpful to other
people who are who are
investing in a different way so you
mentioned the psychology
of money which is a amazing softball for
me to bring up
you wrote the book the psychology of
money um
i've read uh almost two-thirds of this
already
and uh this is the only book people have
heard me talk about books on here before
uh
one i don't really like reading physical
books normally i usually do audio books
or something else
this is the only book that i can
remember in recent history that i've
actually read
and before i move on to the next chapter
i go back and i read a second one
like it's one of these books that just
to me is uh
has so much packed into it in terms of
the lessons and like the way that you
describe it why the hell did you want to
write this well like what was the
like at what point were you like you
know what i'm not gonna go write like i
do on a daily basis
instead i'm going to write this book
well well first thank you and i i would
say i would actually push back on the
last
question because i wrote the book in the
same way that i write
uh that that i write on a daily basis
when i first started to set out when i
was first outlining the book
it was going to be ten chapters which is
kind of a normal length book and each
chapter would be four or five thousand
words which if you're not
familiar with word count a normal blog
post is probably 800 words
so four or five thousand words is that's
a lot of it's a lot of material
and it's and four to five thousand words
is not a length that i have a lot of
familiarity with i don't have a lot of
experience with that length so it was
kind of daunting when i set out
and i quickly abandoned that approach
and i said no i'm going to make this 20
chapters and they're each going to be
about 2 000 words
which is much closer to what i have
experience with
and it's also look from the reader's
point of view i've i've i've been a big
reader for the last
you know 13 or 15 years or so and the
biggest thing that i hate about books
even really good books that i would
recommend is just the excessive length
that doesn't need to be there
just people rambling on and on and on
because it's it's a book so let's just
ramble on for another 50 pages about
this one point
and keep making repetitive examples of
it and i just wanted to abandon that so
rather than writing 10 chapters in which
i would ramble on
i said let's write 20 chapters and i
want to make my point quickly
like since it's a book there's more
depth than a blog post there's longer
stories there's more research and
information
but i really just want to make my point
make it as succinctly as i can and then
get out of your way and move to the next
chapter
there's one chapter in the book that is
400 words which is like one page
and i think that's probably my favorite
chapter in in the book and when i turned
it into the publisher they said
hey is this is this a mistake are we
missing stuff here and i said
no and they said well do you want to add
more to that and i said no that's all i
have to say on that topic
and as like out of respect for the
reader if i have nothing else to say
then i'm done like move on i'm not going
to waste your time
rambling just to prove that i can write
a long book
so uh what is i think naval says like
you know most books should be blog post
most blog posts should be tweets and
most tweets shouldn't be sent
right type the situation so i think very
similar here uh in that uh
it's very concise right and kind of
jam-packed with information
um the topic the psychology of money uh
timeless lessons on wealth greed and
happiness
why that kind of uh focus versus
you know the plethora of other ideas and
and things that you could have written
about or that you have written back in
the past
i think so i want to start the motley
fool i was a banking analyst my job was
to cover
bank you know wells fargo earnings and
stuff and then um i quickly
i kind of transitioned from that into
covering the economy so most of my time
at the motley fool i was writing about
like the components of gdp and what
inflation was doing that kind of stuff
and then i kind of transitioned in my
later time in the motley fool and the
last four years of collaborative fund
to what i write about is kind of
investing history and investing
psychology and where those two things
meet up
and i'm most interested in that because
to me the biggest story
prior to march of this year prior to
covet was the
the the great financial crisis 2008 and
most of my time
as a writer has been writing about why
that happened and like what we can do
about it in the future like
what were the causes of it what were the
incentives of it and to me the causes
of the financial crisis cannot be found
in any economics textbook or
any financial textbook they're found in
psychology textbooks and sociology
textbooks and history textbooks
like how people think about greed and
fear that kind of stuff that that is not
something that lends itself to the
analytical side of finance where all the
attention goes the analytical side of
economics
it's just a it's this soft kind of mushy
topic that gets swept under the rug in
investing
swept under the rug in economics because
it's soft and mushy and you can't
explain it in formulas but to me it's
the single most important aspect
of investing and of economics is the
behavioral side of it the psychological
side of it
you can be the best stock picker in the
world you can be the best economist with
the most sophisticated model in the
world
but if you panic in march of 2020 or if
you lose your mind in september 2008
none of it matters
none of your analytical ability makes
any difference in the world if you're
going to lose your mind
during boons and bus and so that's why
you know
this the psycho the psychology side of
money is not the only important part but
i think it's the most important part
because it can neutralize
all the other anal the analytical parts
of investing so to me it's always been
the most important i also just think
it's the most interesting it's not just
a bunch of dry numbers and charts
it's stories about how we behave as
people which applies
outside of investing the the
introduction of my book is called the
greatest story ever told
and i think that's what money is because
we learn so much about money
um that uh that applies to other areas
of our life
like it money just teaches us it's a
windowed into how people think about
risk and greed and opportunity
which is applies to how people think
about relationships and careers and
politics
and all these other areas that that
don't seem like they have anything to do
with investing but they all fall under
this umbrella
of how people behave yeah and i guess
what's really interesting is
so go back to like march uh i i'm pretty
sure the data has come out now
that uh most of the people who panicked
and sold were
older folks right who basically were
trying to protect their portfolios and
all this kind of stuff and they
basically sold at you know 15 20 percent
down
uh and then also the market turns around
and kind of it through
one of the things that uh is kind of a
consistent theme i think in your writing
is basically like almost preventing
yourself from yourself
right or protecting yourself from
yourself talk a little bit about
um kind of the psychology aspect you
know just like you are fascinated by it
i think
most people say like oh that's a really
interesting thing but it's also
operating within this highly complex
system of like the psychology of a 30
year old versus a 70 year old
in a market panic they're optimizing for
almost different things in many cases
right so kind of how do you think about
almost the external forces
uh impacting or playing on to that
psychology
i think it's a big issue that you
brought up because there's this implicit
assumption this unspoken assumption
that there should be one right answer to
investing questions
and you know what is this stock goodbye
you know is this asset allocation smart
or not
and obviously everyone has completely
different
uh expectations and goals and whatnot so
if you watch cnbc and they're talking
about you know is microsoft a good buy
is is this a stock you should own well
are you a teenage day trader are you a
90 year old widow like it's completely
different
but we never we rarely talk about
finance like that it's always
spoken about you know one answer to
things and you can even
bring this down to i think one of the
major causes of bubbles and i write
about this in the book
is that bubbles happen or at least one
of the reasons that they happen
is when momentum entices short-term
traders like there's
there's momentum in stock so short-term
traders rationally and reasonably they
come in and say well i
i want a part of this there's momentum i
want to take some of these profits and
then that
that pushes up momentum even more and
that starts getting people's attention
and then long-term investors watch what
is going on
with these short-term momentum traders
and they take it as a queue they take it
as a signal
to say oh well maybe they know something
i don't so maybe i should go
all in to these ridiculously inflated
stocks or any other asset real estate
whatever it is
and then long-term investors start
taking their cue from short-term traders
and then and then everything goes to
hell and it's not until hindsight that
you're like
look at the people like let's let's
let's take housing for example let's not
talk about stocks but
if you look at like condos in miami in
2006
a huge portion of those were just being
flipped every 30 or 60 days
and so those were just short-term
traders and you could say like
they weren't even irrational because
there was momentum they weren't making
money at the time
the problem happened is when people who
were long-term home buyers they were
looking for a place to raise their
family
took their cues from those prices and
they said oh let's go buy some florida
real estate
and then two years later they got
hammered so i think that's like just the
idea that people are playing totally
different games but we're all on the
same field
and we're all trying to take cues from
each other that's like the basis of
finance is taking
cues from what the like market signals
what is the market telling you
well if you're playing a different game
from other people then this the
signals it's giving you might be
perfectly rational and good information
from one person
and completely dangerous nonsense to you
and it's so hard to separate that in
real time but it's so important to
understand
what your own goals are what game you
are playing and try to only take cues
that are relevant to that game and those
goals
i love it psychology of money timeless
lessons on wealth greed and happiness
uh one of the most popular questions i
got when people knew you were coming on
is when the hell is the book coming out
the book the book comes out september
8th and people are asking that because
i've been plugging the books since
february which i don't know in hindsight
if that was a smart thing to do
but um it's created i i think it's just
setting up people for disappointment
because when you set up that much
anticip you know eight months of
anticipation then when it finally comes
out
you're like this is what i've been
waiting all year for but for better or
worse that's that's what i have the the
turnaround on books
is obviously so long i finished writing
this on
on january 1st that was like i wrote the
last sentence on january 1st and i
turned in the publisher
we had finished editing it by like may
something like that maybe june
and then it goes through like the
process of getting it printed getting
inventory sent out getting everything
like it goes from the printer to the
distributor to the bookstores to amazon
and like it takes a while to get
everything turned around
can people go to amazon and pre-order it
now yes
okay all right everyone go pre-order it
it's a fantastic book highly suggest
uh before we get into more of the kind
of finance topics uh there's a lot of
questions about
just content uh how you learn to be a
good writer what your process is
uh not writing the book but just kind of
the more daily content you put out
talk a little bit about you know you get
to motley fool
you it sounds like you weren't a writer
at all didn't really understand what you
were doing like
how have you picked up and honed that
craft over time and what does your
process look like today
i think it's those two things the motley
fool one is that when i started
i was writing three articles per day
every you know five days a week which is
a tremendous
amount it's too much and like because i
was playing the volume game three
articles a day like they weren't any
good because i was just i had an hour
to think of an idea type it out and get
it sent out
um so it was just a really but that much
volume when you're writing that much
three articles a day every day for years
just that much experience
anyone will gain a little bit of skill
in writing just by should just
by just sheer repetition the other thing
that was really important is that
these articles were public because
mollyful had a big platform even though
i was a brand new writer
tens of thousands of people were reading
these articles and leaving comments on
them
so the feedback you know like most
people if they have a brand new blog
like realistically they don't have any
readers so they're not gonna get much
feedback
very minimal feedback but i from day one
the first article i wrote i had
thousands of comments of feedback and a
lot of that you know people as you're
aware from twitter but it was more so
in the comments section because it was
more anonymous if you write a bad
article
people will tell you in no uncertain
terms so i just had so much feedback
and i was had so much volume experience
i was doing it so much
that i think that's the best way that
you can learn is when you have a lot of
repetition and a lot of constant
feedback
you put those two things together uh and
then over the course of 10 years of
course you're going to gain some sort of
of of skill if you have those two things
and you don't get better over 10 years
and then there's something wrong with it
so that was that's where i learned to
write i write a lot less now i only
write one article
per week now and the process now is
you know there's not a lot of structure
to it i don't know if this is going to
be that much of an interesting story
because there's not
there's not a big process that i have
it's just a lot of reading a lot of
going for walks and thinking about
whatever topics are on my mind trying to
piece things together what
like what what have i read recently that
i thought was a really neat story and
how does that apply to something that i
can tie back into economics and
investing
and oh this reminds me of that and that
reminds me of this it's just a lot of
just wandering around my house thinking
about those things
and then so that's that's 90 of the work
is just kind of aimless reading aimless
going for walks and thinking sitting on
my couch and thinking about things it
doesn't look like work but it is it's
trying to piece things together
so by the time i actually sit down and
write an article that's like maybe
10 of the actual work it doesn't take
that much time to sit down and write it
um and the other thing that's true about
the writing this is true for i think
every writer
if they're honest about it at least is
that when i sit down to start
start writing an article i really don't
have much of an idea of where it's
gonna go because the process of writing
is what makes you think
it's like you write one sentence and
you're like oh that reminds me of this
and you write another sentence and
you're like oh wait does that contradict
something else i wrote
in in the previous paragraph so now i
gotta change that it's like
it's not like you have the whole thing
laid out in your head and then you sit
down and just smash the keyboard and
it's done it's not like that at all
it's this process of the like the the
practice
it's often viewed as writing is the way
that you communicate but i don't think
that's
that's
really the case at least that's only
part of it writing is the way that you
think
writing is the process of of getting
your your thoughts out there and
crystallizing these vague thoughts that
you have in your head
um so that's that's really there's not
much more to it than that it's just a
lot of reading a lot of thinking and
then just kind of grinding through
it doesn't get any easier over time i i
think the actual writing the actual
clicking the keyboard gets easier over
time crafting a sentence gets easier
over time
but piecing things together um is i i i
don't think i'm ever going to run out of
material but it doesn't get
easier over time it's still kind of a
day it's still kind of a weekly grind to
figuring out what i'm going to write
about next
it's interesting because uh it reminds
me of the saying and i'll butcher it but
it's basically like if you got to cut
down a tree spend you know four hours
sharpening the uh the axe before you
start swinging type situation right
somewhere here of like you spent a lot
of time thinking and then
you have a general idea of where you're
gonna go and so
do you ever get like writer's block or
anything like that in terms of you've
already done
you know a lot of the kind of mental
work of okay this is the topic and
here's like maybe
the pieces that i want to put together
in it um does that help you kind of
avoid any sort of
writer's block or do you still get some
of that the most
important part about writer's block for
me is this if there's one metric
that i know of and which is going to
predict whether an article i write is
going to do very well
it's how easy it was for me to write the
article if i if i sit down and write an
article and it's just comes out so
easily
it just i just hit the keys and like
like first draft is perfect
those are the articles that are going to
do really well if i'm struggling to get
through something
and i'm just writing i'm like ah this
isn't clear it's not good i don't know
what i want to say
that's always because i don't think
there's any exception to it that's
always because
the idea that i have is not right it's
not a good idea
and i'm struggling to write it because
the idea sucks
versus if the idea is good and the idea
is clear it's really easy to just
go out there and type it out and put it
out there so whenever i get to writer's
block
it to me that's a signal not that i'm
i'm struggling with
writing it's to me that's a signal that
whatever my idea is my
thesis for the article is wrong and i
should take a step back and say
you know what's going on here i think if
there's a if there's like a skill when
you've been doing it for more than a
decade is that
i can quickly kind of triage when that
happens
and say oh okay look i've been working
on this piece for only 30 minutes but i
can already tell this is not going
anywhere and let's just abandon it and
move on
and i think that's a really important
thing versus just struggling and working
so hard on a piece
that you know is going to suck and then
you put it out there and it's going to
hurt your reputation no one else is
going to like it too so
that's that's always a signal to me for
writer's block it's like a great
investor cut your losers early
jeff that's exactly it's the same
philosophy yeah um
so a lot of this obviously is you are
consuming tons of information you're
ingesting that you're synthesizing it
and then you're kind of putting your own
unique perspective and then
um kind of creating your own content i
saw a couple people asking what are the
uh types of content that you consume
and also what do you pay for versus not
pay for
um and kind of i think people are really
just looking for recommendations in
terms of like
what does morgan think is high quality
content that maybe i could read as well
so let me start with what i pay for i
pay for wall street journal new york
times the economist
the atlantic that's it yeah that's
that's what i pay for
and and those are great those are great
for news like capital and news
journalism which is really important but
you're not going to get the really
nuanced take
from that kind of stuff those are good
to get your facts about the world um but
the
the takes i i get which is the really
important part virtually everything i
read comes through twitter
um and and and books i would say those
are like that's like the barbell of my
information intake it's just twitter and
and books and i would say if there's a
if there's one philosophy that i have
about reading it's that
i i think i got this idea from patrick
o'shaughnessy where he said you want
a really wide funnel and then a really
tight
filter so i try to read anything
and everything that might look slightly
interesting to me
in a wide variety of topics i almost
never read investing books
but i read books about all kinds of
topics and i read articles about
all kinds of different fields not just
economics and investing but
politics and biology and history and
biographies like all
kinds of different stuff a really wide
filter but then the type
a sorry a really wide funnel but then
the type filter
is again just like writing i think i can
triage really quickly
when i start reading something within a
couple sentences to say nope nope this
is not
this is not for me i'm out of here it's
either bad writing or it's about a topic
that
that just i'm not interested in so i
think that's
a good reading philosophy whether it's
online or books
try to get your eyes on as many things
possible as many shots on goal as you
can
but then cut your losses very quickly so
you can move on
people should not have any um any guilt
whatsoever
reading books including my book to if
you're reading it and you don't like it
don't waste your time
put there's a lot of good books out
there don't waste your time on bad ones
don't burden yourself with bad books
um so that's that's the that's the
reading philosophy that i have i try to
read as much as i possibly can and move
on from the bad stuff as quickly as
possible
i love that um you mentioned earlier
investing in
index funds uh while being in kind of
this culture of
stock picking uh maybe talk a little bit
about how you think about
your portfolio construction today and
how you choose to get
various exposures just so as we kind of
talk about more of the nuanced financial
topics people understand kind of the
perspective you're coming from
yeah so i've written about this a little
bit in in the past but my entire net
worth
is this house a checking account and
some vanguard funds a little bit of
berkshire hathaway and that's it
that's that's everything i love that
simplicity and i value that simplicity
that's i i would not even recommend that
that is
the that that most people or even you
know some people like that's what works
for
myself and my wife and my kids because
to me the metric that is going to make
all the difference in the world for me
over my lifetime as an investor my
lifetime as
a human and as a father and a husband is
going to be how long can i remain
investing for
and i know that if i dollar cost
averaging the index funds and i leave
them alone for 30 or 40 or 50 years
i'm gonna hit every one of my financial
goals and then some
and therefore like that's to me that's
everything that checks all the boxes of
what i want
i don't aspire to be the world's
greatest investor i
aspire to be a great writer that's
what's that's what's important to me
but for me to go out and beat the market
on averages
you know this year and maybe i can keep
that going for a couple years that's
just not
important to me but i it is important to
a lot of people and that's why i'm not a
passive zealot
i'm not one of those people banging the
table saying everyone else is a [ __ ]
who's not doing this
to me it's just this works for me and
everyone's got to find something that
works for them
and i want to spend all of my bandwidth
thinking about the psychology of money
the psychology of investing
and none of my bandwidth thinking about
what what industry is going to perform
well in q3 that's just not i don't have
any
interest in that whatsoever so to me
it's just kind of like finding your own
goals and what works for you
um to me i i also have i've just
embraced just as part of my personality
that i have a lower risk tolerance than
a lot of people would for my age and
income and net worth
and i'm okay with that i don't try to
fight against that or try to you know
change who i am it's just this is who i
this is who i am
like for most people or i don't know
about most people but a lot of people
our age anthony would be
what matters to them is like swinging
for the fences making a lot of money
and what really matters to me more than
anything is that i can go to bed every
night and look at my wife and look at my
children
and say you guys are going to be okay
we're all going to be okay we got
whatever happens we can we can withstand
a category 5 storm like we're going to
be okay
that to me is that's my biggest goal but
i know that's not a lot of people's
biggest goals so i always love the
phrase uh personal finance is more
personal than it is finance
and i think we need to embrace that more
in in
the financial twitter communities and
whatnot that there's no one right
answer for people and a lot of the
debates that we have about
this person thinks x and this person
thinks why they're actually not debating
they just have completely different
goals that lead them to a different
area and they have they're playing a
different game i think that is a a
very rational view of the world uh and
one that is missing
quite often especially in uh was it 240
characters
that's right it's hard to share that
nuance um
talk a little bit about uh you have
relationships with and uh one of the the
impetus for this question was uh you
know many of the best investors in the
world from a pretty
objective um just data-driven manner uh
many of them are on
you know findwood on twitter and then
other relationships that you have
how do you um kind of gain comfort and
really have the patience and discipline
to do
what's kind of best for you when you do
have all those relationships or i think
a lot of people they kind of fall into
i don't have access i couldn't do that
anyways but what you do have potential
access
how do you still kind of remain
disciplined and really it's kind of a
more of a
how do you control your psychology right
as you uh have this plan
well i think there's two parts of it one
is to me
there's really not a lot of temptation
because of what i just said about
what is really important to me is just
you know thinking
if i can dollar cost average for 40
years then
every one of my financial goals is going
to be met times 10.
so for me there's not a lot of just
temptation of like oh i can go do that
and to me the idea of hey if i invested
in in better funds i could earn higher
returns this year
to me i would almost put that in the
bucket of yeah and if i got a second job
i would i would have more income this
year i i almost kind of equate those two
some people like maybe that's not the
best
the best analogy but that's kind of
where i put it it's like
i i could earn higher returns investing
in other funds but it would pull me away
from things that i really like and from
like
the psychology of thinking about my
finances in a way that is really
appealing to me which is
super simple really basic i have all the
numbers in my head because there's only
like four assets that i own
in everything it's really it's really
simple for me and that's just that's
just how i like it and it
if i can do that and meet all of my
goals
then why would i want to do something
else that's going to be more complicated
or more risky
i think maybe that's a big part of this
if there's one part of
my and my wife's personal finances that
i'm most proud of
it's that we have gotten the goal post
of financial success to stay pretty
stable over time
and i think for a lot of people the goal
post is always moving so when they have
higher income better investment returns
they get a big windfall
like if the goal post moves in tandem
with that then you never feel like
you're getting
ahead but for us like the goal post has
stayed fairly stable so even though as
we have gotten ahead over time
incomes have gone up the market's done
very well you know this is the the worst
economic crisis since the great
depression and my
my index funds are up like 12 this year
so it's like if like if you can have
that and your goal post stay steady then
to me like
then the appeal of doing that much
better kind of diminishes
like if i had way higher aspirations
back to my
my when i was 19 that i wanted a bentley
and a house and i haven't if i still had
those aspirations then i would be
chasing down
my great investing friends to try to get
ahead but since i
i i don't um it's just like
what i do now checks all the boxes that
i need to yeah it's pretty interesting
like if
uh you almost think of it like a
percentage basis the difference between
120 and 130 percent of your goal
just how much extra effort would it take
to to get that extra 10
seems to uh almost not be not be worth
it in some cases for some people right
right i mean i'll give you one example i
won't get into the
to the details but we got a modest
financial windfall
two years ago um it was it was it was
meaningful as a percentage of our net
worth like it was pretty meaningful
and when i told my wife about it she she
just said
is this going to affect how we live and
i said no and she said she said
that's fine then i don't i don't i don't
she just didn't care
uh it was just it was like nothing and
from for a lot of people would be we got
this windfall where we can go buy a
bigger house go for a bit and for for
her it was just like well if it doesn't
change how we live then who cares just
like it's just a game it's just the
numbers on the board that doesn't
and i i love that moment because that
was the best indication of like
our goal post has stayed steady in a way
that we're totally content with it's not
like we're
holding ourselves back and saying we
would rather go out and spend our money
on this but because we want to be frugal
we're gonna we're gonna deny ourselves
that pleasure if we can actually
legitimately remain comfortable with the
goal post where it is i think that is
how you gain
actual happiness with your money because
now everything that we save
since we're not spending it on stuff
every dollar that we save
is just like a little bit more financial
independence that will let us go out and
live whatever life we want to live
retire whenever we want to
live wherever we want to it's just a
level of control over our time
um that that is meaningful to us in a
way that
you know a higher level of material
living is not necessarily important to
us
absolutely and and maybe talk a little
bit about um
you spend you know most of your day if
not all of your day thinking about
financial markets psychology of money
like things that are related to money
investing and markets
um how do you and your wife kind of
think through
financial planning right there's a bunch
of people who've come on the podcast in
the past and
uh one person in a relationship is uh
well-versed and spends all day and kind
of like it's almost like their
occupation or
related activity uh the other does not
and so kind of how do
how do you think through um almost this
uh arbitrage of information right it's
not even education as much just like
somebody's reading all day about
something and somebody's not so how do
you kind of
um you know fit that into the model of
creating a financial plan staying
disciplined et cetera
especially maybe even in terms of chaos
as well like where you just might have
you know better access to information so
i guess there's two important parts of
this one is that we've been lucky and
that's that's the right word it is just
dumb luck
and that my wife and i see completely
eye to eye on spending
which for a lot of couples that is that
is not the case and that's a big
big issue so um you might i think my
wife and i have been together since
maybe she was 19 i was 21 something like
that so
you know the majority of our adult life
and the number of
spending disagreements that we've had
like i'm sure there have been a couple
but i can't think of any it's always
been really
pretty eye to eye so that's a huge
component of our personal
finances the other component is that she
is
much smarter than me she has a high
school diploma she went to high school
unlike me
but just like leaving that said she's
much more analytically intelligent than
i
am but she has no interest in our
finances whatsoever
to the point where like once a year i
gotta i have to sit her down and like
walk her through
like our like where we keep everything
but because of that it's kind of
just the level of trust i guess like i
100
control the financial decisions not
because i don't want her input of course
i do it's just
she's not interested in that so i so i
do that on my own
um so if i guess from a planning
perspective our month-to-month spending
has always
remained roughly stable there's not a
lot of change i guess we have two kids
now so i guess there's been like
an uptick due to that but what we spend
money on hasn't changed that much
in a long time um so after so there's no
like okay we're going to spend x and say
why we spend on whatever we want to but
but what we want to spend on is not as
you know of a huge portion of what we
take in so after
after after we spend whatever we want
then a dollar cost average into index
funds the same amount every month
max out retirement funds um and then you
know
there's been some some differences over
time my wife was working for a long time
now she's staying at home with our kids
so that income went away and then we
just bought this house so there was a
big
financial transaction there so it's not
perfectly stable over time
but it's just i think when you have a
when you have a big gap in between
your your spending and your when you
have a high savings rate because you've
kept the goal post
you just have so many options about what
you can do with your money which makes
the decisions a lot easier
absolutely no makes a lot of sense um a
lot of people wanted to know about
uh just your view on uh what is
happening in markets uh we can start
with
uh kind of the disconnect and p e ratios
we could talk
about um kind of the uh the fed uh and a
lot of the quantitative easing you tell
me kind of maybe how you just
holistically look at
uh there's this public health crisis
obviously there's a government mandated
shutdown
uh kind of a lot of uncertainty and
chaos uh in march starts to ensue
the government steps in kind of how do
you look at from once they stepped in
to today like what's transpired and
maybe kind of the frameworks you use
to just think through this i think
um i mean i'm surprised as much as
anyone else that we would be going
through this what
40 million jobs lost and now at a 10
unemployment rate still
and stocks in all-time high and you have
companies like you know you know
car companies like tesla that are up 500
year-to-date
during the greatest recession since the
great depression like it's
it's it's boggling from from like a
first glance but
i i think some of it makes slightly more
sense if you dig into it one is that
of course and this is nothing that's
going to be too surprising but one is
that when we talk about the stock
market we're talking about indexes like
the s p 500
of which are heavily concentrated uh in
a very small handful of stocks that are
doing very well right now
because even with the pandemic their
business has increased amazon facebook
google microsoft apple
those companies even though we're
looking at a diversified index that's
everything
that's like that's all that matters over
time so if you look at you know certain
industries that are much more
tied to main street small companies in
certain sectors
they've been demolished as you would
expect to happen during a depression but
since we're so
we're more concentrated into a few big
tech names than ever before
they kind of mask a lot of that the
other that's been the biggest trend for
the past
almost 40 years that i think is almost
too simple for people for smart
investors to take seriously
is just the level of interest rates of
course stocks are going to do well
when investors who have who have to do
something with their money say okay i
can earn zero percent in bonds
zero percent in cash or i can pay 30
times earnings for microsoft or whatever
it is i don't know if that's the case
but
of course things are going to look more
appealing at ridiculous interest rates
today with zero percent
rates than they did 20 years ago when
you could earn eight percent on treasury
bonds like
of course that's the case um so the
biggest
i mean and that's why value investing
hasn't worked in the last 15 years is
because
when you have when your discount rate is
so low then
what a company's gonna earn this year
does not make that much of a difference
it's what the company's going to earn
over the next 20 years that really
matters
and uh and that's why even this year
where you know if s p 500 earnings were
wiped out this year
in a discounted cash flow model doesn't
make that much of a difference if your
year one earnings are wiped out and your
discount rate
is zero like no it doesn't make that
much difference over time
um so that's part of it and the other
thing is of course the fed which is just
pulling out the howitzers and the
bazookas and just blasting money
throughout the economy
and of course like is that going to have
is there risk to that of course is there
going to be ultimate repercussions of
that like
like likely i don't think we can say
certainly because the fed's been doing
this since 2008
and a lot of the repercussions that were
so obvious to people that have always
been just around the corner have not
played out a collapse in the dollar
hyperinflation right around the corner
things that made a lot of sense to
really smart people in 2008
haven't played out and i think if people
are not honest with themself about
asking why did those things not have not
played out why have we not turned into
zimbabwe like it seems so obvious in
2008
then if you're not asking those
questions i think you might be missing a
big part of
of fed mechanics and what might happen
in the future it's not to say that
there's not going to be risks like of
course
to me the biggest part of inflation i
don't want to go down too much of a
rabbit hole here but inflation is
obviously
too much money chasing too few goods
people spend too much time
too much effort on the on the money part
of that equation and not enough
focus on the good side of that equation
so every historical example of
hyperinflation
happens when yes you know a regional
economy is printing a lot of money but
also when their industry their economy
is
broken and they can't produce goods
anymore it happens after wars when their
factories have all been bombed into
rubble
it happens in places like zimbabwe when
the government confiscates all the the
productive assets or venezuela when the
government comes in
the only productive assets in the
country the oil fields the government
confiscates them runs them into the
ground and they can't produce anymore
that's when that's when you get
inflation risk and i bring that up
because
2020 is the first time that we've seen
in a really long time maybe the first
time
in modern american history that we've
seen
industries that are fundamentally broken
that's going to
um really prevent their wave their their
ability to produce over time
particularly industries like hotels and
airlines
that are just going to be so broken that
even that when you
when this is over however you wanted to
find that when there's a vaccine or what
not
if you have tremendous pent-up demand
for travel
for flying but let's say by by next year
american and united are bankrupt or
they've laid off half their staff which
is a more likely scenario
then you could have a ton of demand and
not a lot of goods because the hotels
are i've gone bankrupt airlines aren't
flying like they used to
that's when you could get legitimate
inflationary pressure so it's not
just about what the fed is doing or how
much money they're printing it's about
you know the fundamental health of the
economy and the fundamental healthy
economy is
more broken now in 2020 than i think
it's ever been in our lifetimes
and how does something like um you know
this morning
jerome powell gave a speech that uh
pretty much people
i think have been uh rumoring that he
was gonna give which essentially just
says hey look we're gonna keep a
higher level of inflation or target a
higher average inflation level
uh which people you know are talking
about okay they're gonna overshoot the
two percent for some period of time
uh and kind of just create this more
inflationary environment
uh does that change anything in terms of
that analysis of the demand
and the goods um is there a level of
kind of the
demand that once you go past you know
some trigger point or
milestone uh it's kind of the point of
no return or do you think that it always
stays
as a relationship between the demand and
the goods
i don't i mean it's it what's what's so
hard about 2020 is that you have
you know 40 million people lose their
jobs but then incomes average incomes
increased during that period and hidden
and savings
savings savings rate is off the charts
retail sales adjusted for inflation are
at an all-time
high so there's not a lot of historical
analogies when you could look at that
during the great depression
unemployment was 25 and people's incomes
fell like 40
so completely different from what we're
dealing with today so how do you
forecast future demand in a situation
like today
where especially as coven 19 lasts you
know
we you know back in march we were hoping
this would be a one month or a two month
ordeal
but now that it's at least a six month
and probably a one year maybe a two year
ordeal
every month that tick by that ticks by a
greater share of businesses
that had just laid off workers
temporarily are done they're going to
close their doors for good
and that way and then because of that
even when you get a vaccine when this is
over
you can't just bring all those workers
back you just have a higher structural
level of unemployment like we did in
2008.
so is that going to is that like that
would of course lead to like lower
demand but now you have
both the congress and the fed
i think learned after 2008 what you can
do with stimulus
and whatever limits they thought there
were to stimulus before 2008
um kind of like the milton friedman era
of like of you know
low government intervention you know fed
needs to needs to be careful
all that was thrown out the window and i
think because after 2008
both the stimulus package which was
about a trillion dollars in 2008
and what bernanke did in 2008. now you
have both congress
and the current federal reserve saying
hey when the economy is weak
we can just pull out the nuclear the
nuclear bombs and just drop them all
over the economy
and we can do like free like in 2008 the
stimulus package was i think 800 billion
and people's jaws were on the floor
and now we're like hey let's do three
and a half trillion and people are like
yeah that's that sounds right this is
a totally different view same with um
with the fed i mean when ben bernanke
was cutting interest rates
in 2007 from you know five percent for
four percent people are saying he's
being reckless he's being reckless
now the fed is out buying corporate bond
etfs
it's a totally different world so i i
don't know
that if we can look at the new world and
i think we you people need to accept and
acknowledge that that is a new world
policy makers have a totally different
view of where the ceiling is
than they did even a decade ago so how
do you measure demand
future demand in that world where even
record high
unemployment rate leads to record high
income and spending i don't know what
happens in that future it might be like
i this is not my
my forecast i don't want anyone to you
know tie this to
what i expect but it might be that
policy makers are better
much better at managing business
declines than they were in the past
now there's a long history of policy
makers thinking that they have managed
the business cycle
and then the next thing you know
everything everything goes to [ __ ] so
who knows like what's going to happen
from there but maybe we have
to some degree we have knowledge now
that
is going to allow us to better manage
the clients that we have before and
maybe the
the cost of that the risk of that is
we're going to have
we're going to have more frequent
recessions or deeper recessions when
they happen
more damage like of course there's going
to be a downside to that but i i
i would not rule out the possibility
just from what we've seen in 2020 so far
that we are living in a completely
different world of managing the business
cycle for better or worse
how does this change like a 60 40
portfolio so i had um the uh
the gentleman who goes by the pseudonym
john street capital
uh on twitter come on and and he was
talking a lot about kind of the the
evolution of 6040 and how that may not
uh work obviously given the the more
macro environment how do you think about
that and
what what are the changes if any that
you expect to uh to see to kind of that
that standard portfolio allocation i
think
you know the obviously the the the ding
against 60 40 right now is that
the 40 in bonds is is gonna is almost
certainly gonna lose money to inflation
over time which
like of course like that's a big that's
that's a big factor that we shouldn't
just poo poo
there's two there's two important
counters to that though one is that if
you look at the long history of 60 40
and you're looking at like a hundred
years of data where like the four
percent withdrawal rate rule
came from in a 60 40 portfolio all of
that data set
includes a period right after world war
ii going into the 1970s when interest
rates went from 2
to 15 um so like there's a lot of
historical precedent
for the the scenario which we're
currently living in right now where you
have
record low interest rates and the
possibility of high future inflation
that's exactly what the country dealt
with for the middle of the 20th century
and that's still where the four percent
rule comes from so
it's always it always feels like we're
living in unprecedented times
like bonds earned you nothing but it's
like no we've been through that before
it's
we we haven't dealt with that in 40 or
50 years but there's a long history of
that
the other thing that's important is that
we probably got spoiled
in the 80s and 90s and early 2000s with
this idea that
bonds were a place where you can earn a
good income not just a little income but
a great income i mean
like 30-year treasuries have
outperformed stocks over the last like
30 or 40 years like a long period of
time so people probably got this idea
that
the 40 in your portfolio the bonds are
also an
income generating like wealth creating
engine and that's that shouldn't be what
they're there for
they should be there the 40 of your
portfolio or whatever it is maybe it's
70 30 or whatever the portion is
the sole purpose of that should be a
protection
against needing to sell your stocks um
uh in during any market decline or
or job interruption whatever it is that
is the sole purpose
purpose of it is like the the airbag the
seatbelt for your stocks
because uh you know having that 40
of your assets in bonds might look like
you are
pessimistic over time that you're
pessimistic about where the economy is
going to go and you want some
diversification
to me it is actually like why you have
that is because you are so
optimistic about your stocks you're so
optimistic that your stocks are going to
compound over the next
20 30 40 years that you want to make
damn sure that you
never have to touch them and by having
40 of your assets
in bonds or cash or paying off your
mortgage like having that as the
equivalent
just makes it so that you are lowering
the odds that you were ever going to
have to touch your stocks
charlie munger says the first rule of
compounding is to never interrupt it
unnecessarily and that's what your bonds
and your cash and paying off your
mortgage should do
it's like you are like that barbell
personality
is hard to wrap your head around to say
you are i'm so optimistic about stocks
over the long run
but i'm terrified and pessimistic about
the short run that i want all this cash
and bonds to make sure that i'm going to
be okay and give me that safety blanket
but i think that barbell personality is
what you need you need to be a paranoid
optimist in investing
and so optimistic about the long run
that you want to make damn sure that you
can achieve the long run
and live through the long run and the
way that you're going to do that is
making sure that you have enough safety
and cash and liquidity to get you
through the short run
the short run is always a chain of
decline and disappointment and
loss and business is going bankrupt and
every year there's a huge news story
about something going wrong in the world
every 10 years the world breaks whether
it's covet 19 or 2008 or september 11th
every 10 years the world comes to a
screeching halt and things start falling
apart
but but over the over the course of 30
or 40 years there's going to be progress
and that's why you're owning equity so
those can compound over time
so when you just view it as um when you
the the sole purpose of your cash and
bonds it's not to generate wealth like
it used to be over the last 30 years
it's to prevent you from ever having to
touch your stocks
so that they are able to compound to
their greatest degree over time then i
think it makes a lot more sense
what's been your biggest investing
mistake
i mean since i've i've been dollar cost
averaging into index funds for a long
time like almost by definition that's
the reason that you do that is to avoid
some of the bigger mistakes but before i
started doing that
um i uh so here's one that i think is
interesting i read like a lot of people
ben graham's the intelligent investor
over time and i think the first edition
he wrote in like 1934
the last edition was updated in like 72
something like that so let's say the
latest edition is like 50 years old
something along those lines
um and in his book a lot of reasons the
book that's so is so popular is because
he gives
practical investing like formulas like
you should i'm making this up and it's
like you should go out and buy stocks
they're trading for less than two times
book value and less than three times
cash flow
like specific formulas of what you
should do so as a young investor i
looked at that i'm like great he's
telling me exactly what to do i can go
to use a screener and use this formula
to buy these stocks
and a lot of the formulas were to buy
stocks and they were trading for less
than book value like less than
networking capital
which during grams day during buffett's
early days
that strategy worked really well that's
a lot of where buffett's early game
gains came from is finding
stocks or trading so cheaply they're
trading for less than their net cash
value
and so i i started doing that when i was
a young investor
and none of it worked like most of these
companies went bankrupt it wasn't that
they didn't perform well they just like
went poof
and i just realized like a lot of like
what was going on is that that strategy
worked during grams days it worked
during the 1950s it does not work
anymore
because during grams days you had good
high quality companies
like good profitable companies with
great brands that traded for less than
their cash value
and that just doesn't happen anymore
there there's too many fast computers
too many millions of hedge funds looking
for the same thing
that those opportunities don't exist
anymore at least as frequently as they
did back then
and today if you find a company that is
trading for less than its cash value
there's a reason
there's a reason it is that cheap and
the reason is probably because the
company's going out of business
so just just the idea that the world
changed over time and even if you're
looking at something like
ben graham who's known for timeless
wisdom a lot of the things that he
believed and practiced during his day
don't apply anymore
and it's hard for people to accept that
because we want to think that investing
is like physics
like how the world worked a million
years ago is exactly how it works today
but investing is not like that like the
strategies that work overtime evolve
and it's like it's hard to
you know balance this idea of of am i
just falling for like the latest trends
or have trends that that did work for a
long period of time
do those not work anymore and i need to
abandon them and move on that is a
that is a really difficult thing to do
but i learned the hard way that that is
a a a realistic part of every investor's
journey
and i think a lot of people uh forget
that one of the other key pieces to this
is that
the rules change right and what i mean
by the rules is all sort
terms of regulation and things like that
um this past week uh
one of the uh or two of the rule changes
have been uh won some amendments to the
accreditation rules and then also
um some uh changes to the way that
companies can use direct listings versus
going through the traditional ipo
process
maybe either comment on those specific
things or just talk a little bit more
generally about how the
kind of evolving regulatory uh
environment and rules can
drastically affect investors and you
know strategies and things like that
i think in terms of you know better ways
to go public
of course that's that's necessary
because the the normal ipo route
and you know bill bill gurley has been
kind of the leading voice in this but
the normal ipo route is a joke
it's always been a joke there's a reason
that investment bankers have private
jets
and ferraris it's there's it's a very
lucrative field because it is
the fees that are generated by ipos to
the banker is is a joke and two the
early investors for whom they are
allocating shares
is crazy and so to live in a market that
is this efficient
and still be doing things that that
inefficient is crazy of course
but there's also been fewer ipos or
you know not necessarily fewer ipos but
companies are staying private longer
because there's
so much more private capital um today
than there was 10 or 15 years ago or
certainly 20 years ago
there's trillions of more in private
markets than there were 20 years ago so
the need to go public
is not is not as great as it used to be
and i think that's only gonna
grow over time and you have a lot of
companies like
airbnb and uber before it went public
that were able to get liquidity
for their early investors and some of
their employees because the depth
of capital markets in private in in the
private arena it was so much
greater than it was in in previous times
in phil knight's
book um shoe dogs which is about how he
started nike
he talks about that when he started nike
which i think was like the early late
60s early 70s
said there was no such thing as venture
capital and when he was a star
when he was trying to fund his startup
he had to go to the bank and get lines
of credit
like that was his only source of capital
so we've come so far in a short period
of time in private capital markets
where now you know if if the equivalent
of phil knight started today he could
raise
billions of dollars in private markets
without ever going public
so obviously it's a different world in
that sense but of course it's great that
we're
moving towards saner views of going
public
spax which is like the other you know
way that companies are going public that
that seems like
just a flagrant profit profit grab on
the people who are
running specs because there's probably
there's probably no greater
get rich scheme than spax over time
where
you are running a spack if you go out
and find a company and
and convince your investors to buy it
you automatically get 20
of it without having to do anything not
20 of the profits you just get 20
of the company just for finding it like
of course people are going out
and paul paul ryan and uh and now these
people are going out and starting spots
you can make a fortune doing it of
course i'm doing that
um the thing about the rule change with
accredited investors
i mean the the old rules were always
kind of antiquated the fact that they're
not adjusted for
inflation meant that you know it's you
know it's it's been traditionally that
you need a net worth of a million
dollars which back in the 1980s was real
money and today it's
significantly less money so of course
those rules are antiquated
um i i don't think if you were to look
at the universe
of mom and pop investors of people
saving for retirements
and saving for their kids college and
you look at their financial the
financial products that are available to
them
i don't think any honest financial
advisor would say you know what you're
missing
is a hedge fund with a 10 with a 10-year
lock up that's what
that's that's what you're light on you
need like that's just not
it's it's not to say that those products
are not useful but to say that
you know mom and pop investors saving
for their goals are missing out on those
i i don't know if that's that's a really
valid
uh topic and i'm certainly what's going
to open up are
um these kind of products for in small
mom and pop investors where the products
it's not that they are buying them it's
that the products are being sold to them
and you know with a hundred percent
certainty that there's gonna be stories
down the road of a hedge fund that use
these new rules to go out and sell
you know 25 000 slugs of their hedge
fund to a bunch of mom-and-pop investors
with a 220 fee and then everything went
to hell and the fun blew up like you you
know that's going to happen but
um but that said the the rules were
antiquated
in in the past i i i i don't know how
much change it's going to make over time
but you're right like the rules change
over time so we can't look at today's
markets and compare them directly
to the 1990s or 1980s because it's just
a completely different game these days
yeah and i guess on the accreditation
thing like my whole thing has always
been
uh don't make it based on income or net
worth just make it like just create like
the sat for finance
right yeah if you go take this online
test and you pass
do whatever you want with your money
you're sophisticated enough and like
if you're an idiot and you lose all your
money like you know your problem
but if you can't pass like some base
level of
education like one actually the market
will be
less educated therefore less safe in
some way but two is like
you should probably spend some time and
learn about this before you actually go
and do it
and i get the argument for people like
oh well there should be no rules i don't
necessarily agree with that right i tend
to think that like you have to have some
kind of
protections because there are malicious
and nefarious people who will kind of
prey on the on the wrong
population but it definitely feels like
education is a better proxy
for sophistication than you know how
rich you're totally right i mean how
insulting is that that we judge
sophistication and intelligence by
income
like that's absurd i've never thought of
it until you mention that but like
that's absurd
there are a lot of rich idiots out there
and there are a lot of people who
because they are school teachers or
firefighters don't have a high income
but they're very smart people
so of course like that's that's a great
point we we should measure it and like
the
the on the the finance sats doesn't have
to be that
difficult you can make it a 30 question
test that you take online i i totally
agree with that
i i got feedback the first time i ever
said this and somebody said you can't
call it the finance sat because everyone
hates taking the sat you got to come up
with a different name so it's better
marketing to uh to elicit people wanting
to actually sit down and do it because
everyone has uh they're scarred by the
memories of the s.a.t
i i i agree with that
um talk a little bit about uh crypto
bitcoin
um kind of just what your general uh
perspective is on it and
uh and how you think um you know folks
uh that are not in the crypto world kind
of the more traditional
public market private market investors
look at it
i don't have that many that many
opinions on i still i don't own it i
but i'm not i'm not against it i'm just
kind of a fascinated
observer of what's going on with it
because it is it is of course
fascinating something that
obviously looked like a bubble in 2010
has gone on to something that is
mainstream and is clearly
like john pretty sure is josh brown who
made the point
of like if crypto just because crypto
has not died yet just because it's
lasted this long
that is the indication that it's
something if this was nothing it would
have died
years ago so of course it's something
but i i don't i don't understand
i i have not yet found the argument for
why i
need to put my money in it like it just
hasn't been that clear
to me yeah i'm not saying i'm not gonna
get there but i i just haven't i haven't
dived deep enough
into it to quite understand it some of
the arguments
that i've seen put forth for it
i think are are kind of nonsense one of
which is the idea that
the government cannot cannot touch your
crypto like it's this hands off the
government can't control it because the
government can't do anything
of course they can and my example for
this would be go back to 1933
one of fdr's first rules that he put
forth was
it's illegal to own gold if you own gold
take it to the bank right now
and and turn it in for cash and if you
are caught holding it after this
you can go to jail this is what that's
that's what they did they did that to
to control the money supply during the
depression but of course
like i don't think this is gonna happen
but could something happen with crypto
like you say like the government can't
not you but people say the government
can't touch it the government can't do
anything about it
if the government and this is not a
prediction but if the government put out
a regulation tomorrow
that said if you own crypto you will go
to jail if we catch you owning crypto
you will go to jail which is exactly
what they did with gold in 1933
of course that would have an impact on
the price so when people say the
government can't impact it like
yes they can the government has
handcuffs and guns they can do whatever
they want with it
well one of the things that i thought
through and actually uh so i've talked
to a lot of people about
the confiscation of gold and uh one of
the things that for sure the u.s has in
their toolbox they could ban ownership
uh there's literally been um one
congressman i think it is in
california who like he said this a year
and a half ago hey we should ban this
right now
right and his whole thing was like you
know he he read the breadcrumbs and said
oh you know if this becomes successful
the dollar fails well
whatever the whole thing um so i i don't
think that that's something that uh
has not been explored by them or thought
about it right and people who think that
are
uh being naive right at best um but
what is fascinating to me and i don't
know what happened in 1933 on on uh this
perspective is
um the thing that i keep going back to
is like if the u.s was to ban it there's
a lot of other superpowers that
are looking to get off the us dollar
system so whether that's russia china
etc
and is there this game theory that plays
out that says wait a second the u.s and
u.s citizens are not going to use
something like actually we should adopt
it
right and therefore like it's our you
know kind of wedge
to um to kind of get off that us dollar
system and by the way
uh we all we have to do is adopt this
thing that nobody else right
i don't know if that's like an actual
game theory type situation that can play
out it's a possibility but maybe not a
probability in my standpoint
what i don't know is in 1933 when they
banned gold did
other countries react either positively
or negatively to
the u.s doing that i don't know if you
know that i don't know i don't know
that's that's yeah that's a good
question i don't know the details about
that
um but i've always just used that as an
example of like well like what
is when i'm trying to answer the
question for myself what is the purpose
of crypto is it an inflation hedge is it
a currency that i'm going to use to
spend money on stuff
is it to prevent is it to protect my
assets against government confiscation
and inflation
when i'm trying to answer that question
because those are the kind of things
that i grapple with
one thing i would say about the dollar
and i'm not a dollar bull
or bear i don't really have any view on
it but one thing about the dollar is
when people
wonder what is the value of the dollar
what like where it gains its value from
to me it's it's pretty clear
if you want to work or do business in
the united states you owe taxes
you can only pay your taxes in u.s
dollars as long as that's the case the
dollar is going to have
incredible insane amount of value
because a lot of people want to work
here
a lot of people want to do business here
we make great products and the only way
that you can earn
buy those products make those products
be a company that is doing business with
those products is if you pay taxes in
u.s dollars
that's what's going to create the demand
that's not necessarily the case
in venezuela or or zimbabwe
when the demand for those countries
individual unique
non-commodity products is very different
than it is united states
you want to go to school in the united
states you're going to have to pay in
u.s dollars as long as that's the case
and that's that's going to be the case
for i think all of our lifetimes and the
dollar is going to have value it's not
to say that's
that the fed can't screw things up or
there's not going to be periods when it
does terrible but
to me the dollar has a lot of intrinsic
value in it yeah
one of the parts that uh you're
highlighting here is almost this like
uh again there's not one size fits all
and so in the u.s like i think the
system works pretty well for you and if
i need to go get money out of the atm i
go to the atm my
body shows up right if i need to buy i
lived in venezuela very different
yeah exactly i totally buy that and so i
think that
uh one of the mechanisms that
uh again possibility i don't even know
if it's a probability but this idea that
like if you're in venezuela and your
government currency fails
uh i don't think that people buy into
this goes back to the psychology and
kind of belief system of money
if the government's like oh sorry we
screwed that one up like here's the next
one
i just don't think that people are like
oh yeah sure let me just like completely
trust you
i think that they start to look for like
other types of stores of value and
mediums of exchange
but today if you look at like what are
the options for them they want dollars
right like dollar they have
full faith in credit the us government
is stable like like all of that is true
it's hard to get it could be dangerous
maybe there is some there's probably
more confiscation risk in venezuela
obviously in the united states but but
that's dependent on who you are and kind
of where you are in the country whatever
and so this idea that like if i have an
internet connection i can get access to
a different currency than my own i think
is like a very kind of
um it's a paradigm shift now the
question is just like what is that
currency is it a non-state backed
currency is it just the digital dollar
digital r b whatever and so it almost
gets into this world of like
what happens when everything's digitized
right and digital is is basically like
the same technology that bitcoin runs on
to some degree with some variation like
every single currency has that
it's almost like the competition is now
not at the technology layer now it's
actually like a monetary policy thing
and i just don't know like what
percentage of the population could even
describe the u.s monetary policy let
alone other currency poll
you know policies i just i don't know
right
yeah i i i don't know it does seem like
to to put
put one one point in in your scoreboard
it is crazy that we've been
this far into the digital era in terms
of digitizing everything else in our
lives
in fact that you and i can have this
conversation you know from separate
sides of the country
but the most fundamental part of most of
our lives money
and transactions currency has not been
digitized you're right there is a
like a fundamental irony in that uh but
i i just don't know enough about it
to see where it's going to go yet and
and i don't i haven't been convinced yet
that i should
i should personally put some of my money
into it yeah of course that's cost me
yeah that's cost me over time but that's
that's but here's what i think you're
bringing up which is
uh and i've actually been surprised by
regulators and politicians in terms of
their desire
to digitize the dollar right so almost
this idea of like digital money is not
the
you know the negative thing or the thing
that they don't want it's just the idea
of whether the government controls it or
not right i think that's like the
the when you really get at the core of
like what is bitcoin it's the separation
of state and money
which is you know 10 years ago sounded
like an absolutely insane idea
today it's you know one percent possible
right five percent you know what it's
still so small
um but i think it's more acceptable at
least in conversation
than it was a decade ago and the
question is just like where does it talk
about money
but isn't it already digitized like if
the fed credits bank of america
with digital reserves and then bank of
america makes a digital loan
and then wires me a digital deposit like
that's all that's all digital right
so the the big difference and i and this
is where like
uh the the language used
ends up being like very semantics like
the way that i just back out and i look
at it is
if you want to send money quote-unquote
digitally today to
a bank account in another country or uh
even at another bank
it can take you know two days settlement
time sometimes one day settlement times
and so i i always use the terminology
electronic
now electronic and digital pretty much
the same thing but just to kind of
decipher the difference
that makes sense instead what you get is
in a digital currency you get like this
instantaneous settlement or near
instantaneous settlement
now again that doesn't change the
monetary policy that doesn't change the
full faith in credit the us government
the guns and you know and all that
argument it's just
you're just changing the technology form
factor and so to me it's like
it's a foregone conclusion we will get
to digital currencies
it's just which one ends up being
adopted by who because the other thing
is
people like the part i always love is
people think that
187 currencies i think in the world are
all going to disappear and it's only
going to be one
and like the debate's like who's going
to be the winner it's like well i've
spent 187 for a while like i don't think
they're all going to go away
and you're just gonna have one world
currency um so i i don't know it's just
interesting to kind of think through
uh before i let you go i've got a bunch
of uh what i'll call them the more
intelligent questions
that uh that i got from twitter uh and
i'm just gonna run through these
uh so rory karen i think i'm saying that
correctly
asks uh why do you make us all look bad
all the time
what do you have to say for yourself
i'll i'll i'll try to reverse that again
if this is a dare for my next article
i'll try to do something about that
okay uh jim o'shaughnessy asks why do
you hate profits
well he mentions that because as a seed
stage startup working as a seed safe
startup firm the companies that we
invest in are by and large not
profitable
i i turned that around to jim and i said
jim you are a value investor
why do you hate profits that's what i
want to know the companies that we
invest in are not profitable but at
least they're making money for us
the companies that you invest are
profitable and they're junk
jim and i have a long history of teasing
each other about that
jim is uh is one of my favorite people
on the internet because he always
steps in with the perfectly timed gift
he never misses an opportunity so he he
is everyone's like target of who they
want to be in retirement jim seems like
he's living his best retirement possible
he just he just puts out gifts on j on
on twitter all day it seems like a
wonderful way to retire
i love that uh patrick o'shaughnessy
asks do you
do you dream in fully formed paragraphs
and narrative structures
no nobody does right i i think it was
philip roth who said
writing is not hard he said coal mining
is hard he said writing is a nightmare
that's what writing is writing is not
easy for anyone
it's maybe it's easier for some than
others but everyone
like writing is always going to be
difficult
and then the last question before we get
into some rapid fire to end
it is uh brent b shore a little bit more
serious says uh
i guess you and him had a conversation
around risk reward
and the psychological consequences and
he said that you
changed his mind about paying off a
house and to get you to explain that a
little bit more so maybe tell us a
little bit about kind of
not that specific conversation but just
kind of what you guys were talking about
yeah so i i write about this in the book
the last chapter of the book is called
confessions where i kind of
open up the kimono about my personal
finances no numbers but here's what i do
with our money
and one of the things that we've done is
we my wife and i don't have a mortgage
on our house
which is the worst thing that's the
worst investment we've ever made it's
the worst thing we've ever done with our
money
on a spreadsheet because you can get a
mortgage for 2.9
these days tax deductible like it's a
joke that we decline that and put
a substantial portion of our net worth
into a house why would we ever do that
even though i think it's the worst
financial thing we've ever done with the
money it's the best
money decision that we've ever made it
is the one thing that we've done with
our money that i think has given us the
most amount of joy the most amount of
happiness
the most amount of high fives and saying
hell yeah i can't believe we did that
because it gives us so much durability
in our finances
so that as we look ahead particularly
now that we have young kids and that
sort of stability is really important
no matter what happens job losses huge
depressions whatever it may be
like we're going to be okay because we
have this stability and when i go back
to what i was saying earlier like my
financial goal
is to tuck my kids in at night and just
be like
you guys are cool you guys are okay
we're all gonna be fine that to me is
like why i'm doing this
it's also really important because now
that my personal finances i don't want
to say
are indestructible i want to jinx myself
like that but our personal finances are
so stable
it means that the odds that i'm ever
going to have to sell the stocks that i
own
round to zero and therefore the odds
that i can actually leave those alone
for another 40 years are pretty high
just because our month to month cash
flow needs are so ridiculously low
so that's why we've done it i can't
justify it on a spreadsheet
i can't show you a spreadsheet and say
here's why it makes sense to pay your
mortgage off
but it has given us more personal like
family happiness with their money than
anything else we've done with money
and i and i you know when i talked about
with brent that was his argument is like
why would you pay off
a three percent tax deductible loan and
i was like well here's why we did it and
it actually makes a lot of sense and
kind of
kind of showed him that that side
brenda's more money than i do so i don't
know if it's as meaningful to him
but um that's that's that's why we've
done it i love that answer
like that like that is ultimately what
this is all about right it's just that
happiness and peace of mind
so that basically makes complete sense
uh i asked the same two questions to
everyone before
i let you ask me one to wrap it up first
is what is the most important book that
you've ever read
and for you other than your own um
to me the most influential book that
i've ever read is a book by a historian
named frederick lewis allen called the
big change
which is how america changed from 1900
to 1950
and more technological social political
economic change happened during those 50
years
than most two or 500 year periods in
history it was just
like like in 1900 it was horse and buggy
in 1950 it was nuclear bombs and jets
and like the chains that took place from
1950 through today pales in comparison
to what happened from 1900 to 1950
and frederick lewis allen lays out so
clearly how it impacted
american culture from the average
everyday person's point of view
just the average guy who lived in ohio
and indiana and was going to work
like how did his life change during that
period it's so so fascinating
and it just had a big impact on how i
think about economic growth and how i
think about
change like it's so it's hard to think
about
what is going to change the economy over
the rest of our lifetimes
but when you read something like that
you realize that by the time you and i
are 80
we might live in a world that is just
completely
uh that is so different from anything
that we were living in in 2020
that we can't even fathom it today and
that's if you were alive in 1900 and
1950 that's what it was the world that
you
the daily life that you had in 1950 was
unfathomable to you
in 1900 it's amazing uh
second question is a little bit more fun
aliens believer or non-believer
oh i think you have to be a believer you
have to if you if you have any sense of
how large the universe is
like how self-centered do you have to be
to think that we
we we are out of the trillions of
planets we we're just the lucky ones
like how full of yourself are you to
think that about yourself
there's some who who really do believe
that uh that that we're here alone
it's it's the equivalent of like if you
lived in a cave and and you thought to
yourself i'm the only person in the
world with a nose
that's what it is like how full of
yourself are you think like if you
actually know
the numbers of how many planets are out
there to think that we're the only ones
is ridiculous
it's ridiculous one of my favorite
things to tell people is like when i was
in high school there was nine planets
like i'm pretty sure and there was a
debate over whether pluto was one or not
right
now and then and then in college you
realize there's like 20 trillion
yeah now that no like uh i do like it
one day and they're like yeah there's
1400 planets i'm like whoa
where did the other 1391 come from right
and you're just like all right man uh
all right you could ask me one question
to finish up what do you got for me
is 2021 gonna be the best or the worst
year for the economy in history
because because i know it's going to be
one of those two
you think so yes the best or the worst
let me let me give you 10 seconds on on
that we're
either going to find a vaccine and
there's going to be pent up demand
for everything for people to go to
restaurants go to travel everything
and combine that with stimulus it's
going to be just complete economic
bonanza like we've
growth like we've never seen before or
there's not gonna be a vaccine
there's gonna be less stimulus a huge
portion of businesses are gonna go
bankrupt
and then all bets are off it's gonna be
one of those two things
so uh i think that both of those are
fair
potential outcomes the thing that i'm
uh perplexed by and uh i didn't say this
before but
i invest in no public equities other
than uh some gbt exposure in a
retirement account right
so i'm just like a bystander watching
all of this happen and
uh scratching my head being like again
how do tens of millions americans lose
their jobs and
you know billionaires made you know
almost a trillion dollars and all this
craziness going on
what i don't know is
does the vaccine actually matter and
here's uh here's
here's been my argument is even with a
vaccine
this whole idea of like okay now
everyone's gonna get vaccinated
i think that we underestimate how many
people won't take the vaccine
but isn't that like the problem for them
if you and i get vaccinated then we can
go travel
of course of course but there's this
like
it's almost like the psychological
damage is too aggressive of a word but
like
we definitely look at things differently
right so you know i live in new york
city
uh used to go on the subway all the time
uh
and for whatever reason new yorkers are
just like disgusting individuals like
you know you grab the bar to hold on to
whatever
and like you knew it was dirty but you
didn't like
immediately like deal with it but hand
sanitizer on you know whatever
then during this pandemic all of a
sudden they were like oh we uh we're
trying to figure out how to
operationally like you know clean the
subways we've never had to do that
before
and you're like wait what like you guys
never cleaned the subway but you know i
mean like like you just get this like
psychological awareness now that
a lot of things in the world has changed
and so i was talking to a friend and i
said
what would it take for you to go into a
movie theater right now like
is it something that they could do is it
everyone's vaccinated they take your
temperature they test you before you
like what are the things that could
happen
and he literally was like i wouldn't go
like just regardless of whatever you
told me whatever assurances you gave me
and so like that'll go away it's just
like how long does that take
yeah and and i just don't know yeah i i
don't know either to me like what the
like one data point is
1918 was as we are right now worse than
what we're dealing with right now
and i haven't seen any evidence that by
1920 there was any kind of
social you know and any sort of cultural
fear
of flu 1920s with the era of the jazz
bar
and the speakeasy and people going out
to dance clubs
that's what that's what the 1920s were
all about and that was right after they
had a pandemic that was
demonstrably worse than what we're
dealing with right now so if you use
that as a proxy
i i have a feeling look the longer this
lasts then the lower the odds
that this becomes but i have a feeling
that once like this is not how vaccines
work and it takes time to
gain money but i know there's going to
be people who get stuck in the arm and
want to head straight to the airport and
go to disneyland right after that and
there's going to be so much pent-up
demand
do you think it'll be the you think
it'll be the best year ever
i think it could be that's not my
baseline assumption but i think the odds
that it's one or the other are pretty
high
and if you had to pick one or the other
which one do you think that the
recovery and like the positive uh
outcome is more likely than the negative
outcome
i think it's more likely i i don't think
it's likely but i think it's more likely
yeah yeah yeah that could happen and i
think i think it's what people are
underestimating the most and maybe
that's at least one explanation for why
the market looks like it's
bananas right now is because the market
is looking ahead
not that i want to personify the market
i think that's dumb but i think that
maybe that's that's looking ahead and
saying
no if we get a vaccine combined with a
ton of stimulus and pent up demand
things could be ridiculous in 2021.
you'll love this i'll leave you with one
story which is uh my
brother um is he was 23 earlier this
year turned 24.
uh so like literally has robin hood
account you know just starting to invest
like the quintessential story
and uh so sure enough you know one day i
see him playing around his computer and
i asked him i said what are you doing
he's like
i'm looking at stocks okay you know like
i already can tell where this is going
uh and i said you know what what are you
gonna buy and he goes i just bought some
united airlines
and i said why and uh he looked at me
dead square that he goes
planes aren't going away
[Laughter]
and like from a high level like dead on
from like any sort of analysis on you
know why united over anything like
it didn't matter it was just like he saw
one that had dropped a bunch and he
bought it
and uh and and he eventually kind of you
know bust about the stuff we talked
about whatever
but like it hit me there is so much like
the deeper you go into like
fintech or fintwit and like all of this
stuff like the analysis we all get lost
in it
but at some level like there's literally
just people who are just like well
planes aren't going away
right so like i also think i also think
your brother's analysis is probably
closer to good advice than what a lot of
people
with phds will put out there and he just
said it to me like with the most
serious like like duh you're an idiot if
you don't believe this
and i just looked at it and i was like
that's pretty good reasoning
my one of my favorite investing stories
maybe we could wrap it up with this was
it i think it was 1980 um
uh forbes magazine was listing mutual
fund managers
and they noticed that that the top
mutual fund manager
in the country was this guy who no one
had ever heard of um and he had been one
of the top mutual fund managers for two
or three years in a row and he was off
the beaten path he didn't work in
manhattan he was this guy who like
worked in iowa
so forbes or fortune maybe it was sent a
reporter to his office to figure out who
this great investor is and how is he
racking up these great returns and they
get to his office and they ask him
what his investing strategy is and the
manager pulls out a copy of value line
which is this publication that ranks
stocks from one to five
goodbye versus bad buy i think one is
like the best buy he pulls out value
line
he goes i buy the ones that are ranked
number one
that's it so there's and that made him
the best fun manager in the country like
three years in a row
so i think like that simple analysis
actually can have a lot of merit
sometimes
i love that story all right listen
everyone go pick up the psychology of
money timeless lessons on wealth greed
and happiness morgan thank you so much
for doing this we'll
do it again in the future this has been
a lot of fun thanks for having me